that vote to debate was lost
so uh we're going to put to the vote the
notice notice of
no confidence um
council mcgregor you put that motion do
you have a seconder for your
secretary councillor eden
we're going to go to the vote
all those in favor of no no confidence
in councillor conrad it's yes if you
have no confidence and no if you do
so
all those in favor
have you have no confidence in cancer
con it
if you wish to have a recorded vote is
that a request we need five people
we've got five people we'll have a
recorded vote
councillor bill event
against the motion
councillor clarence
councillor colclough
councillor connet
counselor sheila cook
hearing difficulties
counselor david cox
cancer hugh cox
councillor doors
counselor dewhurst
councillor eden
councillor hayes
councillor hocking
councillor gordon hook
councillor jackie hook
councillor jeffrey
councillor jefferies
councillor jenks
councillor kealing
councillor kurzweil
councilman mcgregor
councillor morgan
councilman
that's enough please counsellor nutsley
councillor nuttel
councillor parker khan
councillor patch
councillor john petherick
council linda pedreck
councillor phipps
council of rolison
councillor russell
councillor swain
councillor taylor
councillor 2
councillor wrigley
councillor evans
councillor parker
against
right
that's that's lost that notice of no
confidence has been lost
okay we are now moving on to
and at this time i would say we're
moving to cancer's members questions and
if there are any more outbursts akin to
what we've had a few minutes ago then i
will have no hesitation than suspending
the meeting
so
please
i would beg you
to be quiet
thank you we can now move on to
councillor's members questions which was
the swapped item this is item 18 and we
have a number of questions and i do
restate that a number of questions
um
i believe the number is 32.
um
so first of all we have
a question and these are done basically
in the order that they came into the
council as far as as reasonably per
possible
so the first question was from
councillor bulovan do you have a
asked your question there's a written
response would you like to do a
supplementary
i appreciate the details provided which
was about the cost of
decisions in planning being overturned
and i would ask that the people running
training for councillors be made aware
of the sort of cost to the council which
runs into tens of thousands of pounds
where councils have failed to adhere to
the
national guidelines or the law and
overturned or not
or acted
outside the law in terms of the
decisions made by the planning committee
so it has that to be referred to the
training
for councillors the second question
that i raised was how much has the
council spent
through corporate services on
unbudgeted cost resulting the need to
investigate standards complaints against
councillors when they've those
complaints have been shown to be
unwarranted
and where the complaint has been wholly
or upheld following independent
investigation and that cost again runs
into 13 790 50 pounds at the moment a
considerable amount of money because
counselors fail to understand the
process or the conditions
that they are supposed to follow in
terms of the have you ever got a
supplementary supplementaries can that
again be communicated to councillors
please to understand that the need to
adhere to the constitution of the
council so it's not really a question
just a statement yes okay thank you very
much
right we'll now move on to and can i
just ask we don't need to read through
the questions we just basically want uh
you've had your question as in writing
the answer is given in writing we just
want your supplementary question if you
have one so questions now number one
from councillor mcgregor
cancer gregor's first question then in
other words
it's regarding the executive meeting i
held on the second uh report of items
about driver shortages okay just bear
with me two seconds
they're all in order
yeah i haven't got them in the same
order
okay um on the first question i do have
a supplementary
um with a plethora of driver training
models in the marketplace including
driver retention and cost recovery
what efforts did you make counselor
dewhurst to seek alternative expert
advice that would allow the training to
be carried out and the costs either
recoverable or retaining the driver for
a minimum period
cancer dewhirst behind you please
the boom
thank you um so in terms of driver
training um this is something that i
have discussed at length uh ever since
i've been the portfolio holder for this
with officers
of this council not just a single
officer
i
i felt that
by speaking to a range of officers
over this matter i was receiving a full
panoply of
answers to my questions about training
thank you thank you going to j hurst
okay your second question
or second in this line councillor
mcgregor
about the black bin charge i believe
yeah uh thank you chair um
the previous one was obviously none um
apart from
the fact like with bmqs the questions
are from members to the exec
or council i find patronizing responses
offensive i'll therefore admit to
mention the lack of recycling of cartons
crisp packets and when i talk about
cartons i'm talking tetrabacks and
plastic wrappers et cetera and simply
repeat the question which is what
mitigations will be made for low-income
households
council jewhirst
thank you very much so uh the answer to
that is in the uh answer to the first to
the second question
um and in terms of uh recycling of uh
tetra packs this council does recycle
tetra packs thank you
thank you
question that's not uh i'd like to
actually pause there before we go to the
next question chair and just say that
was not the answer to the question
counselor do has constantly does this he
answers a question that has not been
asked the question was specifically what
mitigations will be made for low-income
households i think really he he has
tried to answer that question i don't
know if he wants to make any further
comment he's
no no no no that's fine so can we move
on to question three please councilman
you're supplementary for question three
you have no supplementary question three
question four then question four
i'm not sure um counselor dewhurst
understood the question i asked you
specifically about the plans you made
with the waste team prior to the current
shortage let me rephrase it for you
bearing in mind you were aware of staff
shortages having campaigned on it for
several years prior to this year as part
of the liberal democrat anti-brexit
stance what contingency preparations did
you put in place to ensure the driver
supply and head count would not be
impacted if there was a staff shortage
thank you thank you question so i'm not
aware of having campaigned uh about
anything to do
with waste
uh staff numbers however when i became
portfolio holder i did discuss uh the
matter of
driver training
and
we did bring in a
training what you might call training
academy
to enable
people
members of staff
from within the council to rise through
and become drivers
so that's what i've been doing uh since
um 2019.
okay please
no outburst please or
this is the last chance
question five in this in this role
um
you responded that um it's not going to
impact the uh planned replacement
schedule will you publish the plan
replacement schedule with expected dates
for the replacement of each vehicle
please
answered your host
thank you very much so
i haven't got the dates with me here but
they the planned replacement of the
fleet
which happens
essentially on a
on a total basis
um it has been in the budget
for some years
thank you thank you very much thank you
all right we'll now move on to some
questions from councillor eden she has a
number of questions and your first first
question i believe is on housing
counselor eden
supplementary do you have a
supplementary i don't and thank you very
much for the very uh articulate response
okay can we move on to your second
question
do you have yours that's
how many properties are privately rented
have you ever supplemented i'm grateful
for the um carefully put together
information okay thank you
the third question was about how many
private landlords do you have a
supplementary for that no i don't have a
supplementary for that either again
thank you thank you for the uh and
right then item uh question four of
yours what steps have been taken to
replace the portfolio order um have you
asked supplementary for that please no i
don't
okay
uh your question number five
regarding the handover have you a
supplementary to that yes i do have a
supplementary for that oh i'm booming um
yes i i don't know uh how much
experience if any cancer con it has of
managing a team of people but isn't it
the norm in organizations and the
business world that if you're sacking
people with zero notice and zero pay to
make sure you know where they are with
projects before you summarily delete
them
since counselor connect was planning to
give this paid position to his colleague
and friend councillor john nutley and
john couldn't start till last week
doesn't counsellor uh connitt think as
the current leader for the sake of
residence he should have
organized a transition who for example
attended the last health and wellbeing
meeting and if nobody attended why not
counselor college if your written reply
were a reply to an a level question i'd
give you an o for omicron
um cancer connie would you like to reply
to that
in terms of exam marks i give councillor
eden euphrates classified thank you very
much chairman
thank you
thank you
if you wanted to be really insulting
you'd say omega because that's the last
letter can we move on please um your
question six have you a supplementary if
you're question six
uh yes yes i do actually um i asked
about a risk assessment and counselor
connect has replied saying he encourages
councillors to follow the code of
conduct that might be a reply to
somebody's question but it isn't a reply
to mine
so i'd like to ask the leader of
cambridge district council councillor
connet how his reply aligns with his own
behavior when he is back to the wrong
man in praising councillor taylor's
attack sax the only exec member who
disagreed with his praising of taylor's
egregious tackle and why he has cracked
down on every dissenting voice when is
he going to end his back sack and crack
version of leadership it's failing us
all
can cancel it
i think the supplementary question
speaks much of councillor eden thank you
very much chairman
okay right uh question seven of yours
regarding the standards um yeah just
just just a quick one um i'd like to ask
the leader alan connect for his view on
the fact that his council decided to
spend two and a half thousand
investigating a woman swearing me but
did not argue to spend one single penny
on the investigation of a male counselor
who physically assaulted another one
i think the response to this question
came from the chair of standards anyway
so um
i think we move on do is that is your
supplementary is it basically yeah
okay
do you want to respond cancer economy i
know it was really addressed too
well it's not even a supplemental
question that was asked in which the
chair of standards answered but the
simple and straightforward answer is uh
the standards committee found councillor
eden wanting it recommend a sanction
which i understand today has never been
carried out by councillor eden she too
might like to apologize thank you very
much
thank you very much chairman i have
concluded my comments thank you point of
order yes right
made a false statement to the council
yes you have counselor eden i watched it
on my
my
zoom screen
apologized unreservedly in public at the
standards hearing and has written and
give provided a written apology to the
town council of tinmuth which was what
was required
and has also resigned her position as a
town councillor in timburth in
recognition of
her falling behind below the standards
so councillor connect has literally just
lied to this council and i think that is
due a sanction
that's that's just a statement so that
do we understand what you're saying so
that's fine
we're going to move on to the next
questions please and that is from
councillor dawes
hi thank you yes you have a
supplementary i do have a supplementary
i know the answers of the question which
as a matter of record
this council failed to call out criminal
actions uh that were taken against uh
waged against newton says no councillors
over three months by
andrew bullivant uh they failed to
condemn those uh uh they've also failed
to condemn the physical excuse me uh
this this this is a supplementary
question yes right i think again down to
the freedom of expression under my human
rights i'm able to frame a question as i
feel state you're making a statement we
want the question so the the the
question is given that this council has
failed to call out the criminal actions
uh of a councillor could it explain why
during this meeting a bbc reporter has
tweeted that they feel rather
disgruntled that this council lied to
them about councillor
gary taylor not being suspended because
he he has indeed been suspended by the
lib dem national party pending
investigation in any normal walk of life
someone would have been removed from
their role albeit temporarily until that
investigation was done so we want to
know the public would like to know why
this person is still in post and why
this council is lying to the bbc
can't reconnect
that was not the case i'm sure it was
not
cancer
chairman if the bbc sound light they can
provide the evidence council malone has
clearly said to the council i've lied i
have not spoken to the bbc chairman
thank you very much
no
councilman please
yeah right we're going to move on we're
going to move on to cancer questions
from councillor mcgregor again
yes you again yes
air quality
air quality and bits and parking roads
okay i do have a supplementary to
question number one chair right carry on
having read the action plan officers are
to be commended for their desire to find
solutions to a problem that is going to
get worse
in your response however you mentioned
that planning
take air quality into account when
looking at applications
isn't it fair to state that you are
deliberately misleading residents
in that response as increased traffic on
an already congested road half a mile
away is not considered in the
application process for that development
all right finished i think that's cancer
dewhirst
thank you um so i'm i'm glad the
counselor
feels that this is
some kind of joke but for the rest of us
we're here to do business
um i thank him for his supplementary
question
and in terms of
the
the the question um i think the planning
team uh do a an excellent job and take
into account uh
um
where the effect of planning uh
extends
in terms of the
the the numbers of vehicles on the road
it's not a given but in fact
the air quality standards will be
decreasing and in fact
air quality standards have actually
improved even though traffic has
increased thank you thank you counselor
you have another question counselor my
gargo
that has been noted
well thank you chair i do have a
supplementary question too number two um
although i will point out to councillor
dewhurst that the person that really is
making a joke of this is the person
responding to the supplementary
questions
your initial answer seems at odds with
the facts counselor dewhurst
as highlighted in the question
specifically related to bitten park road
in tinmuth
the rates of no2 or nitrous oxide
nitrous dioxide i should say in tidmouth
on that road are fluctuating above the
original trigger level that put the aqma
in place this means it is not showing
reductions year on year as you mentioned
in your answer
perhaps you would be best reading the
data provide provided first which
actually came from
the
team bridge's own website
the supplementary question is this
what do you put that the significant
drop in 2020 down to
thank you
thank you thank you um so clearly the
significant drop in 2020 what was the
massive reduction in the amount of
traffic
on on the highway
from lansing to johnny groves and
clearly in bitten park road
that was the case
and
nobody has given
the impression that limits are
acceptable
and this council is working hard with
our officers and with the town council
to bring forward
a an approach that will enable us to
improve
the um the the
levels of
pollutants
in that area we're also working with the
county council as well
thank you country jurassic um your your
question three counselors three i also
also have a supplementary question um i
read through the action plan it's very
detailed and officers again as i
mentioned previously are to be commended
for the efforts they are putting in to
come up with solutions
one particular solution that hasn't been
considered is
unfortunately a little bit on the
expensive side but it is an option
and it's called city trees
and they are specifically designed for
high volume
roots
and reduce
not merely
nitrous dioxide but other
pollutants from the air and particulates
from the air it's particularly important
on a route that is taken by a lot of
children heading to tinmuth community
school
and i would suggest that perhaps um
counselor dewhurst might want to do a
bit more research and actually
look into these things
what commitment can i have from
councillor dewhurst that he will look
into alternative
as yet unlisted solutions
so you have a commitment that i will
look at any yeah anything that would
improve the air quality for people in in
tin mouth and all the other air quality
management areas
and clearly
we
please
and clearly um
that that is the the desire of this
council
i think you can introduce councillor cox
is this relevant no it's not really
relevant is we're just doing questions
councillor cox well it's just just as
i'm no sorry i'm not going like that
i'm going to move on to the next
question and it's
there's some from councillor clarence
you have three questions i believe um
have you got a supplementary to your
first question
thank you very much uh chairman uh yeah
i have a supplementary for all three
questions in fact the first question
uh the leader with respects has failed
to answer the first question i was
asking the leader whether he agreed with
me
having heard the presentation
that the number of stress discharges are
currently unacceptable and this is about
sewage into the team i therefore ask him
again whether he believes the current
number of stress charges
are unacceptable
yes
right right okay question two have your
supplementary
thank you yeah i have thank you for that
our first question that was really great
uh again with respect i felt my question
wasn't answered when i asked
uh now we know the number of stress
discharges and buckland supposedly fit
for purpose till 2035
is he really waiting for the overview
and scrutiny committee to act when the
leadership of tdc could act promptly
rather than pass the matter back to ons
on such a serious matter
scrutiny is a serious business chairman
and the councilors who are on screen
he's done a good job so far and it's in
their power to do more it's about
empowering councillors not but shifting
it back to the executive or ping pong is
about an approach from team bridge i
welcome councillor clarence's engagement
in this matter i've already explained to
him i think there's a lot of evidence
that can be used and it's up to him to
step up to the plate as well and work
with colleagues to get a robust response
that we can take to our parliamentarians
to southwest water to the environment
agency and work with it this shouldn't
be a battle between he and i or between
he and other councillors there's a job
of work to be done does he want to do it
with scrutiny thank you chairman
uh thank you for the answer by god i
want to do it that's why i'm asking
these questions believe you me question
three again with respect uh in response
to my call for action for team bridge to
act does a leader agree with me that
such stress discharges into the team are
a matter for us to deal with rather than
his response claiming that parliament
is the job to do it
can we
uh
be
can't parliament be
expected to to micromanage the
shortcomings
of what we can deal with so it's about
you know chuckling the answer blaming
parliament
it's up to us to do something about it
and and does he agree with me
it's not about blaming parliament it's
about the wider context of pollution in
our waters is a national issue cambridge
district council has a part to play in
that but it's a matter for government
i'm trying to explain to councillor
currents that a though on the amendment
environment bill was not supported by
local parliamentarians i understand we
do have a job of work to do to explain
to them why we would have hoped they
would have uh supported the amendment
there's a big piece of work done as he
knows as well this council like every
other council is required to deliver
housing it's a government instruction
that the council does so we're trying to
work through the twin steps of
delivering the housing that people need
which i know council current supports as
well as ensuring we have good quality
clean water which i know he wants as
well this isn't and needn't be a battle
between us chairman thank you
thank you very much there's a good
answer from alan and i'm sure that this
council will press for for solutions to
this thank you very much thank you very
much right uh we move on now to some
more questions from
councilman mcgregor your first question
in this
round councilman mcgregor
you have a supplementary for question
one um
why did the planning business manager
not correct the for the record
that the land supply was not at risk
during the planning committee meeting
uh recently and that
and and do we briefly supporting the
development not to use misleading terms
that's cancer taylor i believe
thank you for your supplementary
question and a detailed response we'll
get a reply in the members newsletter
thank you thank you your question two of
your supplementary uh no actually no
i do have a question three though for
question three then te3 have you
supplementary
question three legislation seems to
indicate that the outline planning
permission is set at five years maximum
the site has exceeded that by two years
without any notification to the
developer the legislation reads clearly
enough
and as it is now impossible to complete
the opp and development within the
legislative time scales we ensure that
the applicant will seek planning in
principle again for the te3 site
and if you are not prepared to pursue
this as a course of action will you seek
independent legal advice and
demonstrating why
entertainment
thank you again for this supplementary
question it's a detailed response that's
required and you will get
such through the members newsletter
thank you question four have your
supplementary i do
surprisingly
um
privacy was the the basis of the the
question for um and the response seemed
to imply that it was really up to the um
office of concern based on the
individual site requirement
um does that mean the supplementary then
is does that mean there is no consistent
view on what constitutes privacy impact
and if not why not
i would agree there's some subjectivity
to it you there are some
guidelines that are in the local plan
but
i
but if
i feel that there's also some more
details that could be um presented and
as such you'll get a further response to
this supplementary question in the
members newsletter thank you
question five is there a supplementary
there is indeed
um
the the original question was
about
i i do need to kind of give context i
think um just really i know a little bit
about the um
discussions between council and and
other bodies regarding waste discharges
and following on from council clarence
points
with the sheer volume of waste and fecal
matter being dumped into the estuaries
of team bridge and the potential effects
on shellfish stocks other wildlife
tourism and the local economy
would it not be sensible for the
authority to follow advice from the
regulatory body of what
and institute regular ongoing and
detailed discussions about capacity or
should we just let inaction and
complacency lead to the destruction of
our water courses particularly in light
of requirements of the mppf in finding
creative ways to facilitate developments
oh that was it cancer taylor
i don't accept that there's been
inaction but i i will uh ask for a
detailed uh response to this uh question
supplementary question to be
put in the members newsletter thank you
okay
question six supplementary
yes i do
last one does the addition of single or
small-scale development including
windfall outcomes for planning volumes
not figuring any concern for the
capacity
as the poke
focus appears to mainly be on large
developments
entertainer
thank you i'll give you consideration to
this question and uh give a response in
the members newsletter
right okay
uh i think that's you done councilman
thank you okay now we're back with
cancer eden
you have i think three questions here
no supplementaries for one two or three
that's fine okay
now we had
two more questions from councillor dawes
as he's left the building um there will
obviously be no supplementary so that
brings to an end uh
the questions from members
and subsequently the end of the meeting
so
i'll say thank you very much everyone
for being here and just sitting through
this do appreciate it um not the easiest
for all of us at this stage but thank
you very much
and we will see you at the next meeting